hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
en la última década más de 16 millones
de personas abandonaron haití el éxodo
se agudizó tras el terremoto de 2010 que
dejó al país en ruinas provocó la muerte
de más de 300.000 personas y desplazó
internamente a cerca de un millón y
medio de haitianos los años siguientes
no han sido buenos y desde julio de 2018
el país enfrenta una crisis
sociopolítica y económica sin
precedentes esta situación lleva cada
vez a más personas a salir del país
algunos viajan a la vecina república
dominicana pero el rumbo de la mayoría
de eeuu
sin embargo suramérica es también una
opción en brásil los haitianos
representan la segunda mayor comunidad
extranjera sólo por detrás de los
venezolanos actualmente viven unas 107
mil personas procedentes del país
caribeño fueron atraídos por las
facilidades para migrar que ofrecía
brasil pero con el tiempo muchos de
ellos se desencantaron por las
dificultades del día a día que
empeoraron con la pandemia
luís rolle y marian con él nos cuentan
más
en el centro de río de janeiro los
comentarios de la asociación maguana
distribuyen cestas de alimentos para
migrantes en situación de precariedad
hay harina azúcar arroz
es todo lo que necesitas en una casa
pocos en el amigo como ver es
haitiano fue uno de los primeros a
llegar en brasil en 2010
desde entonces ayuda a sus compatriotas
a diario ver el desencanto derivado de
la crisis económica que ha convertido a
brasil a un país de tránsito para la
diáspora haitiana aquí muchos haitianos
llegaron a brasil pensando que estaban
en estados unidos o en europa queriendo
ganar en dólares buscando buenos
salarios pero un buen salario no existe
aquí todavía hay muchos haitianos en
presente pero la mayoría se ha ido en
busca de una vida mejor a otros lugares
hace nueve años apoya a su comunidad que
en su mayoría vive en las favelas de río
puede llevar las cestas a mi casa y
luego las familias quedarán a buscarlas
vive con su familia que también es
haitiana en febrero perdió su empleo en
la construcción por causa de la pandemia
hoy trabaja como empleador de comida y
no conseguía enviar dinero a su familia
en haití cuando llegué aquí un dólar
valía 25 reales hoy precisamos de casi 6
reales para un dólar como decido yo es
muy difícil de ayudar a tu familia en el
pan cuando vives entre sí tienes que
elegir se personasen fast amigos es su
cuñada tardó casi una semana para llegar
a bryant fue hace un año cuando tuvo que
cruzar tres países en avión y autobús
dejé a mi familia en haití tengo otros
dos hijos es realmente difícil pero no
tenemos opciones porque nuestro país va
mal muy mal
a pesar de las dificultades rubens y su
familia no quieren empezar de cero en
otro país esperan puede volver a haití
algún día sin embargo y como lo dijimos
al principio de este programa hay
algunos haitianos que llegan a brasil de
paso ya que su destino final es eeuu
para eso cruzan varios países de sur y
centroamérica antes de alcanzar la
frontera norte mexicana datos recientes
publicados por el instituto nacional de
migración de honduras revelan que los
migrantes provenientes de haití que
llegan al país corresponden a un 45 por
ciento del total de migrantes que
transitan por su territorio veamos más
en el siguiente informe
hasta trojes una pequeña localidad en la
frontera hondureña llegan a diario cerca
de 400 extranjeros la oficina de
migración no estaba preparada para la
llegada masiva de migrantes que
incrementó desde noviembre pasado entre
enero y abril ingresaron por trojes
1.048 haitianos según el instituto de
inmigración para poder salir de aquí
deben pagar 200 dólares de multa por
haber ingresado irregularmente al país
todo el dinero que nosotros tenemos
pagado al papel van a gastar el día que
llega para entregar papel para nosotros
pagamos ya no vamos a tener para
propinar ese dinero van a gastar los
problemas económicos los obligan a
quedarse en honduras hasta que consigan
pagar el salvoconducto mientras eso pasa
la región está desbordada pero los
haitianos esperan poder avanzar
yo tengo siete años y jairo mi país pero
está buscando vida mejor porque mi país
no es bueno no tiene tu aval a la verdad
tienes cosas en trojes hay seis
albergues dispuestos para acogerlos pero
son insuficientes para hospedar a los
cerca de 1.500 migrantes que permanecen
allí para ellos
honduras es una de las tantas paradas
que deben hacer en su tránsito hacia
eeuu
hay mucho mafia en las células de panamá
matando nosotros con una pistola con
machete
con todo quitaron lo que tenemos como yo
somos víctimas de ladrones
yo ando con dos niñas el viaje para
muchos de los haitianos que hoy están
aquí comenzó hace años por lo que
retornar no es una opción
y es que antes de honduras algunos
haitianos han cruzado hasta 8 países
brasil bolivia perú ecuador colombia
panamá costa rica y nicaragua pero ese
no es el fin del trayecto porque aún le
restan kilómetros por delante en su
tránsito por guatemala y méxico hasta
aquí inmigrantes de france24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]